tanti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono pari 10 siamo tornati
incredibilmente sole visti inside era
successo un pò un casino perché ho persi
salvataggi li mortacci mi ogni 4 secondi
mi succede di un gioco sporco demonio
sono dovuto tornare al punto in cui ero
prima arrivati su the beast inside in
modo tale da poter continuare la storia
da qua erano rimasti che il tipo ha
attirato centinato rocca scad di sotto
con la cassaforte in faccia cosa si
trova qua dentro una pozione polisucco
cos'è sta roba mica che cassaforte
incredibile per un foglio tra capitolo 6
vabbè giulia pronto a strangolarmi tra
fosse stato per l'uomo con il cappello e
la maschera lui ha deciso il giudice
norton davanti a me che ha tagliato la
gola sembrava che volesse salvarmi ma
perché che ne sa ci fu ucciso ma questa
quella parte dopo che io avevo visto che
era successa quella roba lì quando ero
arrivato con la pistola ma se non sto
capendo una sega di quello che sta
succedendo però sono tornato ad essere
quello di prima
quello che andava in giro con la pistola
che non ho più ottimo giuseppe i
biscotti stanno guardati stanno
osservando ma quali quelli erano della
scusa non so la chiave non deve
ritrovare da 207 c'è scritto 20 non c'è
gesù dove la 307 aiuto vabbè andiamo
avanti noi chi se ne frega bella con
questa reception questo prego entro gli
fa niente
fa niente vado avanti senza le chiavi
giorno lei non è il benvenuto qui sa
sono incastrato tra le sedie
mi scusi venghi qua dove va mi scusi ma
dov'è andato
l'ho perso in un secondo devo andare la
madonna dei quadri scusate mi devo
andare nella stanza 20 ti vuoi fermare
un secondo per cortesia vieni qua dove
sei entrato qui dentro può essere ma a
porte chiuse è aperta a noce laccio io
lo sapevo però non ho fatto niente
perché lo sapevo sarebbe andato fin qui
c'è una sega
non quella che pensate voi entriamo la
prima perché tu dovresti entrare in
questa stanza poi tra l'altro c'è la
serie con la quale posso aprire l'utile
posso tagliare la catena ma non vedo il
motivo del perché dovrei farlo però
vabbè fa niente andiamoci acciarino
l'inchiesta quando me lo aspettavo
porca vacca salve questa ma spero
veramente ci sono ragazzi di sopra si
sono praticamente è come se fossi nel
sottosopra sono l'inferno rimette avanti
devo bravo spacca tutto perché posso
salire quest'opera va bene bene se
stanze però a dirci che cosa avrà ecco
la sega cielo è una sega dai prendi la
prendi al 3d a sega usciamo a posso
tagliare proprio qualsiasi porta che
figo perché figate credibile
poi giù lei che sta qua e si diverte e
adesso vengo anch'io come si italia
buongiorno lei aveva una bella faccia e
c'era dice la madonna quando la madonna
ce n'è una che mi difende mi scusi e sua
questa madonna qui scusi maria non
volevo la smetta di essere brutto lei
che fastidio alla chiave la prendo 106
secondo la seconda è perché c'è una
seconda la del è cascato un lampadario
devono scavalcare pure di qua casinò
ragazzi c'è veramente un'altra chiave
ala alaa
ok
tra la tua madre nicchia sta rimettendo
imbarazzante sto gioco ragazzi porca
vacca 18 open e qualcosa mi dice che
stavolta non va aperta però io la apro
se permetti si può aprire con la chiave
che bello mettere un lucchetto dove la
combinazione scritta sopra look e cioè
proprio antislavo lo avverta non avrei
dovuto lo so non mi spunta satana come
minimo dove la madonna ma che il demo
gorgone così trovato usciamo non si esce
style.it guardaci padre pio a noi gesù
no scusa ci sono proprio tutti cioè
madonna ci sono foto registi gioco
incredibile proprio un crossover
papaveri che devo tagliare quei cosi
aspetta gesù devo scusa devo prendere le
forbici mi servono viscusi le prendo un
attimo devo tagliare devo tagliare la
cosa lì la posso tagliare anche senza
domanda ok quello che volevo farlo io
avevo già capito bene aiuto aspetta
fermi sei mosso
se non solo zio se non solo dio
ecco
per miglio
l'amica nemica
voglio taglio tonio tonio taglio eccolo
grazie a una visita oculistica la
consigliera consiglierei c'è una bomba
ho trovato una bomba lancia lascia la
via anzi mettere in tasca bravo scappava
che roger cori
bello è stato proprio un bel un bel plot
twist
vabbè comunque questo e per chi si mette
contro di me punto a capo
ma io chiamo molto bene molto bene con
un mastro barbiere o ecco i miei capelli
quando quando crescono a dismisura
il risultato comunque è questo un coso
di chiavi mazzo un coso può essere
utilizzato per le stanze 107 208 peng
cin tesi ritornare alla reception stavo
proprio per dire che secondo me alla
reception non ci torno easy qui la porta
a chi li ha portati via volta la porta
la porta a bada sicuri che scappa scappa
scappa scappa scappa scappa scappa
scappa veloce a distanza risponde mi sta
proseguendo la zia
beh va beh gli armadi che volano mondo
convenienza aiuto sono entrato in un
buco buchi oddio dove stiamo questo tipo
lo porchio anche ottimale e scendi
scendi non si scende non si scende
porca vacca porca si può passare di qua
non si può passare io posso buttare o
buttalo giù ma aiuta lo buttano veloce
che poi c'è un casino dietro di me
potevo fare così anche molto prima in
realtà però devo fare a work azzurro
no mi chiamerà che questa era questa
vermette potente rai a port klang mi
sono ragazzi di sopra marchio
meno male che piove marika la fine gira
e rigira torniamo sempre qua ma porco
demonio
cos'è che avevo visto c'era qualcosa che
ho visto porca vacca ragazze vado al
nostro gioco e si è intensificato
nell'ultimo cesure sul finale
incredibile cioè finale no perché ancora
no anche perché c'è qualcosa di serio
trenitalia si si si nascondo dai qua c'è
quello con un piede di porco in mano va
beh posso entrare nella porta mi ha
visto mi ha visto mai visto visto non si
può uscire aiuto
vabbè si poteva uscire io io volevo
tornare indietro fortissimo avevano
sbarra e che ne so io penso e ci mancava
solo questa
pensa che segue questo posto è ridotto
così pensa come sono ridotte le miniere
c'erano idea
e
ok ma non lo so però voglio andare via
da qua immediatamente dove devi correre
come un puledro ai cori
esci nostro posto inutile scavalca
l'armadio dio mio che anziana donna non
puoi scavalcarlo e basta olio cuore in
ogni e spingi l'armadio nel frattempo
arrivato satana alle tue spalle ma fa
niente
ecco satana intendo lui
forli aiuto aiuto aiuto adige non è vero
non è vero si apre sia per si apre
sempre si aperta ma come cosa
apri veloce quanto te madonna che culo è
uscito aiuto ma ci passo lui e ciccione
non ci passa forte bravo mica grazie
alle miniere di moria l'ha aperta la
porta alla madonna
ieri ha via via via via via via
arrivabene come possibile scelta di
trasporto ma come e allora dico senti
però non può essere ovunque
porca vacca come si guarda indietro
mentre si corre non si può non è come
volta sora vivo l'ho preso
madonna regata che giochi credibile
questo tempo aperto spazi
dissi
[Musica]
beh però sali la crollando tutto
eccolo volante è allora di qua
permettono sono stato proprio madonna
molto corre non sono stato bravissimo
no ma ragazzi incredibile c'è un'ansia e
un'ansia continua non so dove andare di
qua però c'è
wrestling la vuoi smettere di seguirmi
che fastidio sono alle miniere sono le
miniere sono le miniere sono le miniere
sono le miniere sono le miniere sono la
miniera posto a posto a posto tutto ok
la torcia sono caduti in un buco
va bene raggasonico quello qui il peso
di teppisti insight tranquilla esso
continua perché ho ripreso i salvataggi
in grazia di dio
quindi lo finiamo spero che gli sia
piaciuto un bacino iscriviti al canale e
schiacciata a campanellina prima di
agenti sono i video che sono ragazzi
come sempre celiamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]